un téléphone je vous en avez un ou en
vrai et voilà alors on y va André vous
dites que vous faites plus de 6 iPhone
c'est ça plus le 6 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 iPhone
André
je sais pas ce que vous allez gagner le
droit de revenir
et des APN comme ça vous les verrez que
sur ces 8
c'est le voilà ça c'est quand même un
apning voilà merci Jordan Deluxe d'être
avec nous et merci mon André on passe
partout que j'adore qui est avec moi
lors de ma première sur France 4 qui m'a
toujours porté chance mon passe partout
qui a toujours été là pour moi on allait
rigoler je me rappelle sur France 4 moi
j'avais lancé une émission et j'avais
mis passe-partout rappelle tu t'en
Batman
c'était incroyable c'est incroyable et
André il est toujours là voilà pour moi
il sait que c'est un pote et qui sait
que je l'adore ça se passe bien fort
Boyard très très bien tu emmerde pas
là-bas
maintenant je tenais de souhaiter un
joyeux anniversaire aussi
vraiment c'est vraiment une tendresse et
une amitié pour André folle parce que
c'est un amour de mec on a vraiment
rigolé ensemble on a fait des trucs de
fou et voilà il sait que je il est
toujours là pour faire des darka et
c'est pour ça que je le kiffe de fou
alors Jordan donc c'est vrai que ça fait
une petite polémique ton histoire est-ce
que vous êtes choqué vous par ce qu'a
fait ce que vous comprenez la polémique
oui ou non la question est-ce que vous
comprenez la polémique oui ou non bon la
vue Jordan bien entendu chez le Verdez
toi mon Jordan toi tu es comme moi tu
fais des rigolades avec des dés mais moi
c'est l'autodérision et ça vient pas de
Jordan c'est de moi c'est moi qui lui
dit j'ai envie de le faire voilà donc
Jordan il est pour rien là-dessus mais
non mais en plus c'est pas ça c'est
qu'il faut que vous sachiez que vraiment
André c'est un pote voilà André il fait
qu'il se marre il se mord tout le temps
on lui a demandé plein de trucs voilà il
aime se marier et voilà André il est
très bien dans sa peau
exactement ça se passe très bien dans sa
vie André je pense que tu es très
heureux dans ta vie et d'ailleurs
j'avais une idée dis-moi pour être
peut-être mesuré avec des iPad
Guillaume non je comprends pas le tous
les deux en plus qui se sont moqués de
cette séquence sur France 5 avec un
mépris mais horrible
qui est par ailleurs et le mec le plus
ingrat de la télévision française qui
dit regardez c'est sur C8 parce que
c'est celui qui dit vu cette émission
c'est lui qui est par ailleurs la chaîne
qui l'a lancé donc déjà c'est
dégueulasse mais c'est pas énorme
c'est loin il faisait déjà sec Jean-Marc
Mandin qui l'avait lancé c'est
dégueulasse c'est un gras c'est ignoble
de faire ça et franchement c'est très
bien de quoi il oublie tout le monde
après bon après voilà après c'est son
truc mais c'est vrai qu'il a il a il a
fracassé C8 c'est ça Jordan
de la TNT c'est ça aujourd'hui la TNT
aujourd'hui franchement alors bon
anniversaire déjà dans un premier temps
moi c'était ma fête franchement depuis
ce passage parce que nous on l'a fait en
toute bienveillance sincèrement ça va
passe partout André franchement on est
les seuls à l'invité sur C8 entre TPMP
et moi on l'invite pour lui parce qu'il
est André Bouchet exactement pour pas
passe-partout dans cette émission et
tout moi j'essaie de faire des émissions
où on parle de lui de sa famille de qui
il est bien sûr on a essayé de mettre un
petit une petite touche de rigolade sur
sa différence non mais ça fait un bazar
pas possible France 5 moi j'en ai et je
voudrais ajouter une chose que 80 ans
c'est que cette émission c'est je
regarde les cibles à chaque fois c'est
pour les plus de 80 ans après voilà ils
sont très gentils voilà après moi c'est
pas mon délire je l'ai fait une fois
frère il y avait que des des des
personnes voilà qui était décédés qui me
m’arrêtait dans la rue
voilà après c'est tabou voilà moi je
suis pas je suis pas non plus fan des
séries qu'ils ont tendance à se moquer
ils sont dans un truc où voilà ils se
moque de tout le monde nous au moins on
se moque pas exactement on dit les
choses
fait partie du groupe France Télévisions
et jusqu'à preuve du contraire c'est
France 2 qui met à l'antenne Fort Boyard
depuis des années et c'est eux qui
appellent une personne de petite taille
passe-partout depuis 30 ans donc c'est
l'hôpital qui se fout de la charité et
d'ailleurs quand j'ai commencé fort
Boyard j'étais tout petit comme ça
en fait
je vous adore tous les deux et
effectivement d'aider à beaucoup
d'humour et c'est vrai que si tu avais
pas eu envie de ça bah tu aurais fait
couper ou tu aurais fait voilà
tu disais un truc la dernière fois c'est
un truc sur rudy Gobert qui est venu ici
on lui a demandé sa taille aussi il fait
2 m on aurait très bien pu faire la même
vanne avec
effectivement ça faisait un décalage et
tout mais il y a des gens qui sont
grands il y a des gens qui sont petits
et c'est tout et c'est cool
c'est c'est le montage qui est vraiment
hyper hyper malsain voilà cette image ou
pas là parce qu'il arrête pas d'en
parler est-ce qu'on l'a parce que si
vous l'avez pas on en parle on parle
d'un truc qu'on a pas ah on l'a eh ben
on l'a voilà l'extrait de c'est à vous
comme ça moi je le verrai moi aussi
parce que c'est vrai que je vous l'ai
dit je regarde jamais cette émission et
puis en plus je suis un petit peu occupé
à cette heure-ci ça va se plaire voilà
je sens que ça va me plaire j'ai
sentiments prendre un TAC je sais pas
pourquoi j'ai pas mal à m'embrouiller
avec eux aussi ça va m'embrouiller avec
toute la télé
c'est fait avec nous on sera combien
fait l'iPhone notre cher Dédé notre
passe surtout national non vous avez
bien entendu il demande à passe-partout
combien d'iPhone il mesure c'est beau la
TNT et il était tellement fier de la
séquence qu'il l'attisait toutes les
missions François le petit défi des
iPhone du coup bien sûr avec grand
plaisir on va voir si André fait plus
d'iPhone que Star alors je sais que vous
trépignez d'un patience de connaître
l'équivalence de Passe-Partout en iPhone
voici la réponse car oui ils l'ont fait
merci Jordan à demain quelle époque
j'adore la lotte Anaïs avec le moine qui
regarde ça frère on dirait frère on
dirait qu'il a fait un truc de ouf tu
sais on dirait que c'est le truc frère
non mais t'es masses à teute on dirait
qu'il a dit je vais je vais dépecer une
chauve-souris
et franchement Jordan bravo lui parce
qu'il a pas beaucoup de moyens il fait
cette émission il arrive toujours à
faire parler lui avec des gros invités
et des séquences eux ils ont du budget
c'est facile de critiquer c'est facile
ouais en plus c'est déguster
tous les jours c'est à VOUS s'ils
étaient sur une chaîne publique je peux
vous dire l'émission dure pas deux jours
parce qu'il pente pas une pub parce que
voilà c'est fait pas du tout les six
publicitaires c'est catastrophique et
c'est vrai qu'ils ont un certain mépris
pour Jordan Deluxe que j'adore et vous
savez que je défends toujours euh voilà
ce que j'aime voilà et qui arrivent sur
la chaîne et c'est vrai que voilà il
regarde la séquence mais on dirait que
c'est un truc on dirait que c'est un
drame qui s'est passé on dirait qu'il y
a eu un meurtre ça non mais surtout
jamais invité Andrea moi je veux bien
qu'il m'attaque sur les séquences j'ai
invité c'est à vous pour parler pour
parler du lui quoi et pas juste de passe
partout parce que je sais chez Jordan
c'est un programme sur C8 qui est arrivé
il y a quelques jours on est tous les
jours à 9h10 franchement on fait des
audiences on démarre on est content ça
avance bien et on est là pour essayer
justement proposer des choses
différentes sur ces 8 et enfin je sais
pas il y en a une qui aurait jamais fait
ça c'est Apolline de Malherbe que
j'adore
Jamel
Elisabeth Lemoine qui est voilà qui
voilà qui c'est je pense que c'est Texas
2 minutes elles sont toutes ces
émissions là ils ont une testa parce
qu'ils mangent de ris de veau
Espagne pour les taulier non mais sans
déconner allez là-bas je vais m'en
occuper aussi malgré tout Cyril on peut
entendre les gens qui sont choqués
quand même arrêter ça va il a rien fait
là il le fait il le fait avec des dés de
Noël là où je suis pas d'accord avec toi
et on se connaît bien c'est que j'ai été
sa propre
et c'est là la différence c'est que là
tu te présentes comme un comme un
interviewer qui présente pas comme un
humoriste
qui font des apning des lui il se
connaissent très bien
sûr
déjà sur moi-même donc c'est une manière
de parler de l'association
ils ont fait tout un buzz pour ça non
mais surtout à la limite moi Charleroi
bon il veut faire ça pour faire une
darka mais c'est les autres la tête
derrière on dirait erreur qu'ils ont vu
un truc mais on est ils ont vu un truc
alors
moi j'aime bien Bertrand Chameroy mais
c'est le premier à m'envoyer des textos
en me disant franchement j'aime bien ce
que tu fais je trouve ça top et tout et
par derrière il m'éclate c'est toujours
comme ça la télé
et quand ils arrivent à l'antenne ils se
défoncent mais voilà moi je préfère
défonce à l'antenne et envoyer des
textos aussi voilà
non mais c'est vrai voilà c'est au moins
c'est réglé dans ma faut arrêter analyse
à mettre Lemoine et toute cette équipe
là Patrick Cohen et toi
qui arrête de nous gonfler